What happens in a chemical reaction?
Two products react with each other to form new products.
To understand this in a simple way, we can say that A and B react together to give C and D.
Two substances A and B reacted to give us two new substances C and D.
This is a chemical equation.
With the chemical equation, we´ll represent a chemical reaction with symbols.
Clearly, there are two sides to this equation.
On the left, we have substances which take part in a chemical reaction.
They are called reactants.
And the new substances form after the reactions are called products.
Reactants react to form products.
The arrow showed is the directions of the chemical reaction.
A and B reacted to give us C and D.
If there´s any condition it´s written above the arrow.
For instance, if A and B reacted after heat was applied,
it will be written like this.
To give you an example,
we know that hydrogen reacts with oxygen to give us water.
As it´s a chemical change, it implies that a chemical reaction took place.
Using words we can represent the chemical equation like this.
Can we make it simpler?
Yes, we can use symbols off to substances to write the equation.
Hydrogen can be represented as H2,
oxygen can be represented as O2,
and water, as you know, is H2O.
But look at this equation again.
On the left, there are two atoms of oxygen.
And at the right, there´s just one.
Where did the other one go?
It´s this chemical equation correct?
Is there anything more we need to know
about writing chemical equations?
Keep watching our videos to know more.